the U.S has played down an announcement
by Russian President Vladimir Putin that
he'll Place tactical nuclear weapons in
Belarus Putin said he struck a deal with
belarussian President Alexander
lukashenka that doesn't violate
non-proliferation agreements but the U.S
Department of Defense says it sees no
reason to adjust its own strategic
nuclear posture and there's no re
there's no indication Russia is
preparing to use a nuclear weapon
Alexander lukashenko is right he said
listen where are your closest allies why
do the Americans deployed nuclear
weapons at their allies on their
territory trained the crews Pilots how
to use this type of weapon if needed we
agreed that we'll do the same without
violating our obligations I emphasize
without violating our International
obligations on the non-proliferation of
nuclear weapons so let's bring in Miles
pomper he's a senior fellow at the James
Martin Center for non-proliferation
studies he joins us live from Washington
DC miles good to have you with us so
look Putin says this move would not
violate nuclear non-proliferation
treaties he says it's the same as the
U.S stationing its weapons in Europe is
Putin right
yes he is they will not violate the
nuclear non-proliferation treaty because
Russia like the United States in its
with its NATO allies
will retain uh the nuclear weapons
within its own Arsenal within its own
under its own military command
uh until the time of War
so it does not violate the nuclear and
am proliferation treaty however it does
violate uh a statement that President
Putin made only four days ago with
President XI that countries should not
station nuclear weapons abroad So within
four days he's changed his mind
apparently and and Miles the U.S says it
doesn't believe Russia is preparing to
use nuclear weapons it sees no reason to
change what it calls its strategic
nuclear posture is this Washington
saying look we can play this game too
but we're not going to escalate this
development
well I think the U.S is accurate in the
sense that this doesn't really change
the military situation Russia could have
used weapons from its own territory uh
including kaliningrad which is a Russian
Outpost very close to Europe on the
other side of Lithuania and so this
doesn't really change their options this
has more to do with politics uh both
domestic uh and International in terms
of trying to scare people in Europe
especially in countries like Germany uh
and in terms of uh telling the Russian
public that they found some way to use
Russian nuclear weapons what it really
says to me is Russia's losing the war in
Ukraine and Putin is trying to change
the subject
um
this move then by Putin also meant as
you say there to Rattle new European
nerves I mean how worried will countries
like Germany Italy and turkey be as as
U.S nuclear weapons are deployed on
their territory
uh well there'll be certainly be some
countries that will get nervous about it
uh it's this is what why they do it
there are there's always an active
movement in countries like Germany
against uh nuclear issues nuclear
weapons and they know that's something
they can use to try to divide the
alliance I don't think it'll succeed in
that endeavor the alliance has really
held together well uh during the Ukraine
war but
this is a traditional tactic of the
Russian government then they're just
deploying it again miles just a final
thought uh on nuclear command and
control if and when Russia does deploy
nuclear weapons to Belarus how safe
would they be and who would actually be
in control of them who has the finger on
the button as it were
Russia would still have the finger on
the button it would be under the control
of the 12th gumo which is the nuclear
force in Russia in charge of all their
nuclear weapons they would be building
the bunker uh that these weapons are
supposed to go in uh and right now we
should be clear the Russians are not
actually going to move any weapons at
least until July uh in Putin's
announcement he said they would build a
bunker uh to house the weapons so this
is an announcement for the future if it
happens but it's more about saberately
in my view miles pump I really need to
get really good to get your thoughts and
your analysis thank you very much indeed
for talking to us thank you mod
thank you